has anyone ever written to you and said
RB you know I love your site but no
one's contacting me I'm putting in for
these projects and I'm not getting
anything back and you took a look at
their profile and said well here's some
suggestions and this is probably why and
it changed it around all the time and
one of the cool things about the site
and my staff is that everybody is
involved and inside the site even down
to our technical people the people that
actually design the site we're all very
very active in the community and we try
to act as sort of traffic cops in a lot
of ways too you know if you're in the
wrong spot or if you're not quite
getting it here you know we try to make
it it's an extremely comprehensive site
that's a ton of resources and and
features so we try to make you know our
our FAQ area our help area extremely
comprehensive but on top of that we also
get into the site and we respond to
everybody we also check you know if we
just see a post in the wrong spot we'll
say hey you know you may want to post in
this section you're gonna get a better
response but to answer directly it
happens all the time we'll get people
that will say you know I'm not getting
anything out of this site you know
nobody is getting back to me on the on
job requests and things like that then
you go and you look and you see you'll
always see the same issues that the lack
of a bio the lack of a complete you know
Nova I'm an actor but there's no real
I'm a composer there's no samples you
know things of that nature or I'm an
actor and there's no headshots I mean
come on and then the second thing that
you'll see is that they're not active
they're not participating and it's a big
deal David you know we talked earlier
about David Rountree and one of the
things that David said to me was that if
I go to look at somebody's profile and I
see that they're not active in the
community they're automatically
eliminated for me because I feel like
they're just coming in here to be a
one-way street they just see me they see
I'm casting this thing and that and
that's it but they're not contributing
anything to anybody else
so again his mentality is and I agree
with this if they're gonna be this way
offset maybe they're gonna be this way
on set not have the time to waste and I
you know it's hard enough running a set
as it is you don't want you know out you
know people people causing problems and
people that are all about themselves so
it always comes down to the same mistake
it always comes down to its it's social
media you know you need to be in there
you need to be active you need to be
social you need to be networking you
know I'll hear from people that say I'm
getting nothing out of this site and I
go and look at their profile and they
have no network connections you know I
mean they they haven't connected with
anybody well of course you're not
getting anything out of the site you
know it's akin to sitting in the dark in
your house and waiting for somebody ring
the bell and go hey you want to roll or
hey you want to come work on this movie
I mean it's not going to happen it never
does and it's certainly not gonna happen
on social media so let's say someone has
a nice completed bio they've put up a
real they're an actor they have a
headshot they have a great you know
their BIOS has more than just plain
actor
how can they be active on stage 32 are
they like recommending forgive me either
no no it's okay well mainly the stage 32
lounge the stage 32 now what I mean this
is one way I mean there's a lot of
different ways sharing of contents no
different than any other social media
site sharing a content contributing to
threads you know helping people out if
they're asking questions but the stage
32 lounge the way it's broken up
we pretty much compliment every
discipline and every stage of a film
production for example like
pre-production film it you know during
the process and post-production and
things of that nature so no matter what
you this one is there's a place for you
okay and because we live in a world now
you know a DIY world and where we have
more multi hyphenates than ever which i
think is a good thing where we're
wearing you know wearing multiple hats
you know I started as an actor now I'm
actor screenwriter producer director I
have multiple places to go talk to
people and ask questions or you know if
I come across a piece of content to post
it on you know in the appropriate
section there's a currency on social
media and that currency is activity you
know I mean that that currency is is
giving you know I mean it's it's putting
your best foot forward and again like I
said earlier cultivating relationships
the more you do that the more currency
you get then what people look at you as
somebody you know either a and authority
or be somebody that can be trusted or
see somebody that they want to work with
you know I mean but if you're not doing
those things you don't have that
currency and if you don't have that
currency why would anyone want to
- why would anyone want to hire you you
know I mean so if you're gonna be on
social media you really have to work it
you know you got to treat it like a 24/7
networking opportunity right you know
when you wake up in the morning are you
checking your phone like I mean it
deserves that party yeah I mean cuz
sometimes I do that like it and I'm like
what am i doing but then you see that
like it's 24/7 you're always connected
like yeah well I mean from the obvious
standpoint as the CEO of the company
there's the business part of it but you
know from my creative end and you know I
have to balance these two but a lot of
people do I mean a lot of people have a
work life and then you know creating
their getting up in the morning and
writing or they're filming at night on
weekends or whatever we all have to do
you know we'll have this balance unless
we're doing the full-time there is this
responsibility I feel like I have to
myself you know if I'm in screenwriting
mode let's say there's a responsibility
of myself to find hours in the day -
right but there's also a responsibility
to myself to be out there networking to
meet people and I could do that online
so you know if I'm even if I'm online
grab my morning cup of coffee I could be
checking you know the lounge or I could
be checking my wall a check in my
private messages was seeing the new
members that joined the site and saying
hey I want to connect with them and you
know I take advantage of all my time you
know we're always on the go and
everything like that but I'm not wasting
it on Facebook you know what I mean I'm
not I know friends and family you know
they could text me they can call me you
know somebody wants to send me a picture
of their kid they could send me a
picture their kid or what they have from
lunch the consumer I don't need to be on
there you know doing that I want to go
where I maximize my time and that's why
you know I built stage 32 in the first
place so I just think it's so vital I
think it's such an important tool and
you know social media in general is such
an important tool like I said you have
access to people you never had before
why wouldn't you be taking advantage of
that and I think that you know the
mistake that a lot of creatives make is
that they want to spend so much time
creating but if you're not out there and
nobody knows what you what you're
capable of or nobody can see your work
or you know you don't have the right
contacts to see you work or then what's
the point
you